good afternoon everyone
i am christina talbers-legel assistant
professor of general internal medicine
and associate director at the yale
institute for global health
and the yale school of medicine i am
delighted to welcome you
to the yale institute for global health
conversation series
a venue for our community to learn from
and connect with
innovative leaders in global health
coming from diverse backgrounds our
invited guests will introduce us to
cutting head
edge work in global health including
research
implementation policy and many other
perspectives
in addition to the yale institute of
global health
we are indebted to the george herbert
walker jr
lecture in international studies at the
whitney and betty mcmillan center
for international and area studies at
yale for co-sponsoring this series
including today's event today i am
pleased to be joined
by my co-moderator dr onyema aguagu
associate professor of medicine and
director of hiv clinical trials at the
yale school of medicine
welcome onyema it is great to have you
with us today
thank you christina and now let me
introduce today's distinguished guest
dr bernice dawn the former minister of
health
in liberia and current vice president
for health sciences at the university of
liberia
dr don is renowned for her work
rebuilding liberia's post-war health
care
the second liberian civil war from 1999
to 2003
decimated liberia's health
infrastructure and compelled many of its
health workers to flee
as deputy minister for health services
and chief medical officer
dr don was integral in bringing an into
liberia's 2014-15 ebola outbreak
she developed treatment and infection
prevention protocols
organized training mobilized resources
and restored routine health service
delivery
critical steps that likely saved
thousands of lives
after ebola as minister of health dr don
created a
year initiative to improve and expand
the public health workforce
and she developed with partners
liberia's first
national cancer control strategy in her
current role as vice president for
health sciences at the university of
liberia
dr don spearheaded the critical
revitalization of medical
nursing and midwifery schools creating a
new educational and training pathway
for health care professionals in the
country welcome dr dawn it is an honor
to have you with us today
thank you christina and good
afternoon to everybody
it is good to connect once more with
the u.s community and everybody who is
on this in this session
uh we i hope that we have been able to
cope
well with covet and we can move our
lives forward
we will also like to congratulate onyama
who is working
seriously to support some of the covet
prevention activities devicing
production trials and we are looking
forward to
results from there so it can put us at
ease
again welcome to everybody and i am here
to listen and answer your questions
thank you
thank you so much dr don so onyema and i
have prepared a few questions
um we also welcome questions from the
audience please put them through the
chat and
we will look forward to uh sharing them
with dr don as we go along in this
conversation
so dr don let me just start by asking
you
can you speak to how you approached the
concept
of systems rebuilding in a post-crisis
setting
was that response different for
different types of crises
such as a pandemic versus a civil war
and how did you achieve political buy-in
for the response
okay thank you christina
liberia's health care system
have been repeatedly challenged
by crisis so from the civil war
the ebola post ebola
and uncovered
rebuilding for liberia has been in two
folds
from the crisis and then the setbacks
that was caused by the ebola outbreak
in any of those situations strong
government
leadership is very important
there's a need for a well-defined and
well-articulated vision
the vision cannot be in your head
for the entire country so it has to be
documented
and it has to be accessible to everybody
including the locals those who it will
benefit
all the different stakeholders including
those who will support you to implement
them
now in the library contests and i've
seen this
globally also when there's a change from
one government administration to another
it is a perfect opportunity to
articulate
visions and position especially if you
are working in a sector to position the
sector's vision
because at that time the government
and all its partners and
well-wishers who will support the
government to grow
are looking for what looking to
looking up to the government for
leadership for them to make decisions
for example
normally the government will be will be
defining their 90 days deliverables
150 years deliverables
and that is a perfect opportunity
to articulate to use that opportu that
uh
timing to position the sector
so the librarian health sector at the
time
took advantage of that
and at the time coming from war the
human resources were not there
but we also had partners who were on the
ground
who were also
supporting the government during the
emergency phase and was looking
up to the government during the
rebuilding process on roles that they
could play
so we leverage that partnership
using both their resources human and
financial
to develop our first national policy
and strategy so the policy and strategy
was co-designed
with the government in the leadership
the government it is
important to emphasize that the
government have to provide true
leadership
for ownership
and so with that first it helped to
build confidence
between us and the partners
but more importantly because the policy
and those instruments
where it is co-designed
their partners also positioned
themselves
as to how they can help the government
to
deliver things that we all agreed on in
there
remember liberia is a resource limited
country
the entire government budget is less
than
600 million up to today's date
the ministry of health or the health
sector budget
uh for most time range between 12 to 14
percent
of the total budget about 70 to 80
percent of that budget pays health
workers
salary and so there was
like not much left
to even start building the systems that
you are there to build so there was a
need to
work and leverage
partnerships both local and
international
to be able to deliver the strategy in
the plan
so that means we develop a framework
within which
we were going to work
the ministry of health also
develop some financial planning tools
for the health sector so
in developing those tools remember that
we're coming from war most of our
professionals have
left the country there were very few
persons in country who knew what to do
so again we co-designed those tools
the financial uh planning tools
so the plan itself was costed
costing a plan helped to build
additional confidence
partners knew and even the government
knew
at least how much it was going to take
to deliver the plan
and so that help for people to mobilize
the resources
and plan to support its implementation
the tools also help to map
do not support so we were able to map
who the donors were in country
where they were supporting and what they
were supporting
and from the initial stages you could
see clearly there were overlaps
duplications and at that time
the donors were supporting the
implementing partners directly
so with the resource mapping tool
we engaged the donors we were friends
now remember we designed the plans
together
so we were friends and we had to come
back together to ensure that what we all
put in the plan
we were supporting that so we use the
resource mapping tool
to do geographic redistribution of the
resources
so we negotiated with the donors
to support where we think we had
serious gaps and we needed a help
and so that was done and that helped to
bridge some of the equity gap
also now
that system was moving on well
i believe we all know that uh
liberal was able to achieve the under
five mortality reduction
the mdgs within
three years before they ended even
though we started six years late
then we had the ebola outbreak
the ebola outbreak the scale of the
outbreak
took over huemus before the outbreak
in the initial plan we had
a unit designed to respond to
emergencies
and so whenever there was like missile
outbreak
yellow fever object we sent a team to
the county
to support them with the outbreak
of ebola because we had it we we were
all working together we were
and we had a coordination forum that met
quarterly
and another technical working forum that
met week
monthly we
called the donors back and
together we redesigned the emergency
system so the ims the
incident management system was
established
emergency operations centers were
established in the counties and they
were supported with the things that they
needed
the surveillance system was established
also to respond these systems
that were developed in response to the
crisis
transition to more permanent
institutions or procedures
with increasing stability and so the
systems we
established during the ebola outbreak
we transitioned it into the national
public health
institute with all
its appendix still functioning
and it functioned so it had the main
responsibility
of identifying
diseases that had epidemic potential and
responding to them
and so you will realize that during the
outbreak we had the routine we had to
reactivate the routine healthcare
services
and then we had the emergency system the
two
co-existed at some point and that's the
system that is working now
so we've covered the outbreak of covet
it was very easy to reactivate the
emergency the ims
reactivate the eocs in the 15 counties
the surveillance team was also
already functioning so it was a matter
of increasing surge capacity uh
with the covet the team already knew
it is a a disease of epidemic potential
and looking at our situation
uh it was necessary to isolate and treat
isolate people who were infected all
everybody who was inflated was isolated
and treated in a treatment unit
everybody who was a contact was iso
isolated and monitored for the 14 days
or so before they were discharged so
building the system um the approach
was not too different
the strategist policy even in the
emergency we develop plans and
strategies
we align the partners and all those
things we're called on
the implementation to those so we use
the partners based
on your comparative advantage so if you
were a donor you supported the do not
coordination and things that needed to
we needed to implement we needed to help
to implement
if you were an implementing partner you
supported the county health team where
you were with the
emergency operations center and at the
all the way down to the community level
thank you dr don again always nice to
talk with you so
you know i want to follow up on that
question so you know we do know that
while rebuilding health systems it's
really important to
to consider human capital and we know
liberia has significant healthcare
workforce shortages you know it had the
english position of having some of the
lowest ratios you know of healthcare
workers to population
in the world um due to and also
exacerbated by some of the crises you
mentioned earlier the civil war and the
ebola outbreak
so you know my question to you is how do
you address
rebuilding the healthcare workforce and
you know having known of some of your
work we'd love to hear also about the
medical and health sciences educational
programs
that you've initiated to address the
pipeline for health care workers
okay thank you
their vision to develop a fit for
purpose health
health workforce
was articulated well in our
investment plan for building a resilient
healthcare delivery system
after the ebola outbreak so
that vision was a part of the overall
national vision from the beginning
so during the
outbreak we first of all we remember
that we were coming from crisis
we had they had they have workforce and
then
uh health workers died during the
outbreak
also so there was a need to
actually look at how we build the
workforce
and uh normally we do these things
everything is
underlined by an assessment so it's
informed by data
so we first did an assessment
the assessment informed us on the health
workers that we had in
acute shortages
and those that have workforce that we
needed to improve
quality so if you take uh the physicians
in the midwives for example
the findings were for us to improve
quality
expand the skill mix
and increase the numbers
as compared to the nursing
where the finding was and the
recommendation
was for us to improve the quality of
training
and increase the skilled mix
so with the strategy with the assessment
we decided to develop the strategy
and this time around
we came across a strategy that was
similar strategy for rwanda
that a partner in country helped rwanda
to develop
so we engaged our partner and that is
child
to see how we could they could help
the ministry of health to design
they have to bring all the other
partners on the table to design the
health workforce strategy
so that went through a similar process
like the national policy and plan
so we went we we engaged all the
stakeholders around the table
we presented the assessment reports
and we used the report to just develop
what we call the
health workforce strategy
now with that strategy the strategy was
also costed
and so we engaged the partners
to support the strategy they were on the
table to develop it
so a group they had already positioned
themselves
on how they were going to support it so
usaid for instance
decided to support the mid-level
trainings that we had in the strategic
documents so they supported g
pico and some other un
usb ngos to work with those
training institutions midwifery nursing
to re-look at the curriculum to look at
the training resources
the faculty and the systems that will
help to build a
education systems for the health
workforce
so they did that for the mid-level cadet
then we engaged the wellbeing
at the time we were seeing the decline
of the ebola cases
and we had the ebola resources from the
bank
and so we engaged the world bank to
reprogram
the support to support the health
workforce
strategy and because they had a strategy
which was the instrument that defined
the government priorities
they agreed they were going to support
the medical
education now the medical education
in that strategy was in twofold
the undergraduate program
which did not shut down during the war
but the
quality was compromised significantly
and at the time it was graduating like
12 percent
per year and we needed to scale up
the numbers
then we did not have the faculty
to teach the few physicians who were in
country
where they was doing the teaching and
doing the clinical work
and so that also helped to compromise
the quality of the training even further
and so we decided and then we had a
we never we didn't have the residency
training at all
so at that time the assessment report
i don't think we even had 10 specialists
in country for any of the specialties
even if you put all these specialties
together
the sum total was not 10 persons
and so we the weapon decided to
support the medical education
we initially set up the
librarian college office we set up the
librarian college of physicians and
surgeons because we decided the
training will follow the west african
model
and in a west african model uh
the basic medical training is with the
university so that remains with the
university of liberia
and the residency training is under the
it could be directly under the west
african college or a local college so we
establish it
under the local college and
ask the west african college to be to
monitor so we
can be it can be linked to the west
african college
model so we did that
then we built partnership with
first we decided to recruit faculty and
so the lcps the librarian college of
physicians and surgeons recruited the
first set of faculty
for the first year there were challenges
because
once you go on an individual basis
after the first year then they put their
cars on the table
salaries they felt were low
and they started negotiating and that
was also a problem for us
so then we decided to switch
to engage institutions instead to build
partnership with
training institutions universities
they help to recruit for us
from within their network that way we
don't have to deal with individuals we
deal with institutions
and then they can deal with the
individuals
so we did that then
most of the institutions that
we built a partnership with where the uh
u.s
universities we tried the
universities within the region but they
were not as organized
as it is with the us universities and
the um
some of these u.s universities were also
supporting other universities within the
region so they already had the platform
so we negotiated with the u.s
universities to recruit people
from the region since the curriculum is
from the region
so they agreed to that and so the
recruitment of the faculty most of them
came
from the region except where we needed
maybe some specialties
sometimes they brought in faculty
members
from other from u.s universities
the beauty of that
uh relationship faculty members were
recruited to come and teach
in an institution where equipment we
didn't even have the equipment
to teach so the u.s universities
position themselves to mobilize the
resources to help to
to teach also an example
is
we had one of the universities
was responsible for to recruit
faculty to teach surgery and to do
pathology
we did not have a pathology lab we
brought in a pathologist
and there was no laboratory to teach
and so mount sinai who was responsible
for that
actually worked on mobilizing
equipment and supplies to
set up the pathology lab and today we
have
a modern pathology lab
now we also do not have the capacity
to for curriculum development
there are very few one or two persons in
country
for the undergraduate program we decided
we were reforming
first we recruited pre-clinical faculty
from the region
since the clinical faculty share with
the residency training program
faculty so the faculty from the region
are still with us and we decided we'll
reform the medical school
curriculum reforming the curriculum
we are not curriculum aspects but we
engage
the institutions the partner
institutions
to assist us with the curriculum reform
and they consented because they work in
institutions that have
units that look at their curriculum
and so they work with us and
their curriculum as best to
reform the curriculum so we divided our
teams
in departments we do the work
and weekly we have a zoom meeting to
discuss the work we have done
and they gave in their inputs and that
curriculum is coming unwell
now they currently the medical education
is
four years undergraduates
and then a five years medical training
so you do a bsc first in a biology
chemistry or zoology and then you enroll
into the medical school for another five
years which is nine years
liberia happened to be the only country
in the region that has a nine-year
training program others are six years
so we decided to reform the curriculum
to a seven-year curriculum
it should be an integrated curriculum
competency-based curriculum
and that has been done well
now in the curriculum development
process we know that
uh the university processes have to
approve
and one big concern in country is that
the sciences the in from high school
this week we decided to do a seven-year
curriculum
so it's a one-year pre-med in a six
years
medical school
a one year pre-med three years
pre-clinical
three years clinical we know that
if that curriculum goes to the academic
coordination committee for approval
their first question will or their first
concern will be
students coming from high school have a
deficiency in sciences
during the war years there were no
science teachers
so there has been a very big gap in the
training
it is now that the ministry of education
is building the sciences gradually
so we decided to build in that process
a science camp for high school students
so we'll do that two years
before they enter the pre-med to make
them more successful in passing the
exams
and then make them more successful in
pre-med in the medical school
and that will help to reduce attrition
rates
also at the moment the rate is high
sometimes we start with 60 students and
by the
end of the five years you have like 25.
okay thank you dr don i just wanted to
make sure that i didn't step over you
that's fascinating
and it's wonderful to hear you talk
about all this work that we have the
opportunity to
to do in some ways in partnership with
you
i wanted to um pivot a little bit
because we we have noticed
you know of course in liberia there's an
observable contradiction
in the status of women we see some women
like yourself in high positions of
authority
very strong leaders but we also know
that there's much gender inequality
throughout the system
with high levels of gender-based
violence
and disparities in education for women
and girls
liberia's healthcare workforce also has
gender and equity
particularly in the higher paying jobs
and positions of leadership
this problem is certainly not unique to
liberia we face the same challenges here
in the u.s
and globally but i wanted to ask about
strategies
as you're thinking about the educational
pipeline health workforce development
what are you using to improve gender
equity
in liberia's health systems
thank you christina
it is true that
women in liberia have held high
positions
in leadership have occupied positions in
leadership
and it is also true that gender inequity
is also high
in liberia
the first is the culture
we grew up
knowing that we live in a male-dominated
world
in a week male-dominated society
women have defined rules
and so the women themselves
also think
certain jobs are for men and it is not
for them
the previous administration under madame
ellen johnson's johnson-selif
did a lot of work promoting female
leadership
that is not the same with
the government we have today there were
more females in leadership position
in the previous administration compared
to
the current administration
the previous administration of females
in the previous administration
also had more voice
in leadership compared to the
administration today
so how can we affect that
for the future
at the moment we are designing programs
with some of our partners
and
the program is to be able to use policy
to make decisions
and i mean data to make policy decisions
normally if you look at the different
levels of governance in our country if
you take the law because for example
often what you will hear from them is
decision making is numbers so for them
they vote
and there are very few women in there
so their voices are not heard
and then they wear i see law because
doing they are voting too
is i'm supporting you today because when
my time comes
you have to support me also and that's
the politics
when it comes to the executive
is more of leadership
how can women provide leadership to make
policy decisions
that will affect women more positively
and promote women's leadership
and so in our trainings moving forward
is to design trainings
for professionals for policy
makers and will specifically
target more women to do that training
so we'll be able to build the skills
that they need to network
advocate and maneuver their ways
in society
so we purposefully designing the program
to target more women
and people who are at mode are
disadvantaged
as compared to just leaving it open
sometimes you designed a program without
the gender thinking about the gender
perspective
in the design of this program
we look at a data we look at data from
gis one of the partners on gender in the
health sector
and we realized that all the m
e officers in the 15 counties are meals
there were like three different
positions that they were all meals
and then i just reflected and i said but
they started under my administration
so then i began to think how did this
happen
but the design of our project did not
you know did not emphasize the gender in
equity and how to address them
and so uh thinking loud
maybe the m e office us knowing that we
work
in an environment where that is very
challenging you have to move from
most of the time they use motorbikes to
reach to places
so maybe they reproduce subconsciously
took that into consideration and taught
on people who would be able to ride
motorbike tourists so they have
facilities
but you can train women to ride
motorbikes so why we didn't do that in
the first place
so we will purposefully design our
programs to empower women
to be able to hold some of these
positions and to be able to do the kind
of work
that we normally think only men can do
that was great dr don and you know i
think you know one of the
things i've been pleasantly um observing
in liberia is just how um there's much
freedom of speech and people
feel very comfortable airing their views
even in the position unto people of
power
and i hope that you know we can continue
advocacy for the rights and status of
women
in liberia um i have a another question
for you before we
try to tackle some of the q and a
questions um
so i know that the uh the healthcare
workforce program which you help design
and implement
relies heavily on external support both
funding wise and partners like you
mentioned
but i think one thing unique we've done
in liberia
which you somehow touched on but would
like you to expand on
is how we've had support from within the
west africa region
so countries like you know nigeria and
ghana
and how they've provided really valuable
technical support and resources to
liberia's health systems
and medical education so what are your
thoughts around the
advantages of this regional model
and where countries in the region
support each other
and also given that they share similar
limitations and lack of resources
thank you they
like i said in my previous statement
the program was designed based on the
west african model because we live in
the region
and we have to also
follow link to what is happening within
the region
they design itself we pay basis
to universities within the region also
we expressed our vision to them
and they also decided they will help us
so the advantage of having the west
african
college faculty members
to do the training for us
is that the curriculum
is similar the work environment
is similar and
they can navigate very difficult
situations
as compared to if you bring somebody
from the west
who will have everything available to
them
and will not be able to work in your
setting where most things are
lacking as compared to someone who went
to school in ghana
or nigeria who
did not have so much sophistication
the situation especially similar
know how to be innovative and get things
done
and they will be able to use the limited
resources that are available
to teach the way they learn it
and to be able to impact the knowledge
that
you want to have and at the end of the
day it ends up with the same results
so that is a very big advantage and
because we have a west african college
you will realize that our performance
also in the west african
college exam for membership and
fellowship is also very good
we've had situations where
our members went like surgery this year
all those who went for membership exam
pass all those who went for primary exam
pass
we've had situations where all those who
went for pediatrics past in the past
and things like that because the
faculty members no deterrent
they know the situation and so they
adapt
their training to the real
practical realities on the ground
thank you dr don so we'll pivot and um
take a question from the audience here
uh someone is interested
in how students are recruited for the
science camp that you were describing
earlier
okay thank you the students
are not yet recruited that science camp
will start 2021
but we will be recruiting from the 15
counties
initially we had engaged the peace corps
because they were in country and were
teaching in the pacific they were
teaching sciences in the 15 counties
and so we will
work with those who are the trainers to
identify the best science students
we will purposefully ask them to
prioritize females
and we will recruit them into the camp
for training so we will bring them to a
central location
for the vacation period
and build the kind of skills teaching
them
and building the kind of skills that are
required
for medical school critical
thinking writing skills
and those kind of things in addition to
the sciences that they are learning
in the school
thank you dr don um there's actually a
very fascinating question
um i'm going to throw at you from the
audience
um you know we've talked we've focused
on building health systems
and uh you know one aspect of that is
that people should have trust in the
systems that they can receive adequate
care and also trust in
what health authorities which are very
very critical particularly during a
pandemic
so someone is asking a naughty question
and that is what advice would you offer
the u.s
regarding rebuilding the trust of the
public
after seemingly contradictory messaging
during the
kovite 19 pandemic so this is all about
you know messaging and real building
trust you know how in the us
loss of faith in you know systems you
know can impact
people's willingness to adhere to public
health measures take a vaccine if it's
approved so
given your experience at the minister of
health of liberia what advice would you
offer us
about how ways to rebuild the public
trust in our systems
okay thank you lots of public trust
especially during the pandemic
the u.s is not the first during the
ebola outbreak
a similar thing happened in liberia
the public did not trust we had ebola
and so they did not have trust in the
government
people believe that the government
was making up stories to get more donald
funding
and so they did not adhere
to the health instructions that were
coming from the ministry of health
until ebola overwhelmed us
their communities took upon themselves
after that to to organize themselves
to address the issues from the community
level so they were they weren't doing
the helpless caring they have messages
they were the ones who were identifying
the cases for isolation
they were the ones who were mobilizing
resources to support
family members and communities who
family members got affected
that model is what we took
we revised our community health strategy
and policy and that is what we are
implementing now
now what i've realized
with the outbreak of copy 19
the library scenario and the us scenario
my
own perspective is
the not using
data for
decision making this the
the the technicians
are there the u.s government
and that's the interesting thing about
it was the
key partner who helped us to establish
the incident management system the
emergency operations centers
the surveillance systems that we have in
place today that is addressing the covet
issues
what i see with the us those systems are
dead
their routine health care systems are
there the emergency
systems are also there
the difference i see here is they help
us to decentralize our system
and so today the county health teams
respond
to emergencies they start responding to
emergencies
before the national public health
institute goes to assist
and i think that is the difference with
the cdc sending teams
to states to help
another thing i see is the politics
the politics the government and this
happens with the government it is so sad
to say that politicians will use
the population
to remain in power or to gain
popularity the technicians
are giving information and giving
guidance but politicians want to hold on
to
positions want to be seen as working and
so they leave all the data aside
and they follow the politics as a result
things are not working
as it should work in the u.s that's my
own analysis
that also happens here in liberia
sometimes
the politicians will take things we have
had hospitals that were built
in the past because a politician wanted
that hospital in their village
there's a hospital in cape man that no
one patient never entered one day a very
big structure
only because a politician wanted
recognition
the politicians have to listen to the
technicians
they have to work together in the
interests
of the population and not for themselves
thank you
thank you so much dr don it's very
powerful
so we have just a few more minutes um
i wanted to ask you we have many
individuals including students in the us
in liberia all over who are passionate
about the issues that
we've been discussing today and who want
to engage in this kind of work
after they graduate and i wanted to ask
what would be your advice for them
competencies and skills you think they
need
or how you would advise them as they go
forward in their own careers
thank you
my own scenario i was a mid-level
professional
so i graduated from medical school i
worked in the hospital for some time
and at a certain time i went over to the
ministry as a director
with our leadership skills without
management skills
and i still did a chemical with
alongside
the ministry was republic of
work until i went for my
training for
my mph at the university of washington
that training had a component that
focused
on leadership and management
in addition to all even though
leadership and management was built
in all the topics even in the church i
heard that
but there were specific sessions on
leadership and management
and because i had practical
experience prior to going to school
it helped me to map out
where my shortcomings what my
shortcomings were
so it reshaped the way i work and the
way i
think it helped me to develop advocacy
skills
it helped me to learn how to network
among partners my supervisors
leaders to get things done so even if
say for instance if i have a boss and i
have a
vision that my boss is finding difficult
to
i can actually get to another person who
i think my boss will listen to
and that person can help to position my
vision for me
communication skill is key you must be
able to articulate
your vision you must be able to think
strategically and must be able to think
ahead
where you are able to position things
you are able to navigate
the system to be able to get things done
you must be able to know who are your
stakeholders
you should know who can help you to be
successful
and who can help to break you and how
you can bring them together
you must be innovative you must be
thinking ahead
ahead of the work so those are some of
the things that actually helped me and i
actually learned that
after some years of practice i
went back to school i was able to
clearly
define what i was doing previously and
what
i think i could do moving forward thank
you
thank you dr don um i think it's always
just inspiring to see how you've climbed
through the ranks and really left the
footprint at all in
all different levels of the health
system
so i just have one quick question we
have just six minutes before we close so
before i hand off to
christina um to to give a closing
statement i couldn't resist
asking you one last question so you know
we have current challenges including
commit 19
and you've got you've you know showed
leadership during the time of ebola for
your country
um and so i would just like you to in
the next two three minutes just
you know share with us your thoughts as
to what you think
are the next uh big challenges for
global health in the next five to ten
years so
both within the liberian context and
maybe u.s context
we see for example for infectious
disease like kobe 19 how
you know our destinies are tied globally
and
you know that we really have to work
together to confront some of our biggest
challenges so
what do you mean what do you see in the
next five to ten years as being
you know um future global health
challenges
well uh pandemics will always be with us
just how we are trying to solve the
problems with
disease outbreak is the same way the
pathogens
are strategizing to provide to to
challenge us with new objects
so as we design systems we should
remember that we need to design the
systems
yes emergency you respond to it but
think long term
because you will always have an outbreak
that you have to respond to
at least in my lifetime i've seen hiv
blood flow marker disease
cova 19 ebola aversion i've seen some
so it's like we'll continue to have
outbreaks
and so building the systems is
key to managing
both the routine services and the
outbreaks
so there's a need for us to not to give
up on building a system
once the things come returned to normal
we forget
and then we go back to our regular
routine we should always have the
systems
to be able to provide routine healthcare
services
and be able to respond to emergency when
there is an outbreak another challenge
is the
is non-communicable diseases that is
also growing
gradually somehow in the developed world
it has been there for some time
but in the developing world it is
growing
and for us in the developing world
to manage these things is expensive so
we need to
think on preventive seriously so those
are the two
key things that i think we should look
into moving into the future
thank you
thank you so much dr don and
for that answer for this fantastic
conversation today
for taking time out of your very busy
schedule to join us
it's such an honor to have you as uh one
of our conversation series speakers
i also want to thank you onyema for
co-moderating with me
it's wonderful to be doing this together
thank you so much
and i would like to thank the audience
for your engagement
and your insightful questions it's just
been wonderful to have everybody
together today
thank you so much and with these remarks
we are concluding our 2020
yale institute for global health
conversation series
thank you all again for joining us today
and we wish you a safe
and joyful holiday season and a happy
new year thank you so much
thank you and thanks to all of you i
hope
i was able to meet your expectations
thank you thank you so much
thank you dr don
bye bye everybody